merci la parole est à monsieur arnaud
viala merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
un million de 355 milles ce chiffre
c'est celui de l'augmentation du nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi depuis 2012
triste record le record du quinquennat
lui s'établit à 6 millions cinq cent
soixante quinze mille demandeurs
d'emploi mais il va encore grossir
puisqu'il y avait 25 milles 900 inscrits
supplémentaires en catégorie a sur le
seul mois de décembre 2016 à eux seuls
ces deux chiffres claque comme un
couperet terrible celui de l'échec de
votre majorité celui de l'impasse de
neuf cent mille français de plus de 50
ans sans travail ils sont deux fois plus
nombreux qu'en 2012 celui de la
désespérance des jeunes celui du
mal-logement révélé ce jour par la
fondation abbé pierre
de plus de 12 millions de français qui
sont 63 soit mal logés soit mal chauffés
souad à l'ubs doit la plus profonde
précarité financière
celui enfin paradoxal de l'
incompréhension croissante des chefs
d'entreprises partout sur nos
territoires qui s'efforce de relever la
tête qui accroissent leur activité et
qui ne parviennent souvent pas embaucher
nous ne nous entendons jamais monsieur
le premier ministre commenter ces vérité
cruelle
nous ne nous entendons jamais monsieur
le premier ministre les intégrer à ce
que vous appelez le bilan réussie du
président hollande
nous ne nous entendons jamais monsieur
le premier ministre expliquer
l'inexplicable
l'heure du bilan a pourtant bien sonnés
et je vous demande monsieur le premier
ministre de l'assumer sans le rejeter
sur d'autres et de dire à la
représentation nationale le regard que
vous portez sur votre échec et sur les
conséquences de votre refus de rendre au
travail sa juste place face au besoin
pressant de la modernisation de
l'économie française de libérer
réellement les tpe et les pme de la
pression fiscale et administrative qui
les étrennes de permettre l'innovation
et la créativité afin que nos jeunes
puissent oser à nouveau en france de
rendre à la france sa compétitivité face
à nos concurrents
je vous remercie
l'apport l'état madame emmanuelle cosse
ministre du logement et de l'habitat
durable
écoutez profitez-en vous voulez parler
des difficultés des français du mal
logement alors parlons-en
puisque c'est là aujourd'hui le jour de
la remise du rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre
vous l'avez en effet dit pour pouvoir
trouver un logement accessible il faut
aussi avoir un revenu et la lutte contre
la pauvreté je pense notamment au plan
de lutte contre la pauvreté pour
l'inclusion sociale que nous avons
menées dès 2013 avait effectivement pour
but de permettre à des français aux
faibles revenus de seloger mieux de se
loger dans des logements à des loyers
abordables
d'où l'augmentation de la production de
logements sociaux d'où l'encadrement des
loyers aujourd'hui à paris demain 1er
février à lille l'année prochaine dans
l'ensemble de l'agglomération parisienne
vous voulez des actes je vous en donne
moi la question que j'aimerais vous
poser c'est est ce que demain la loi sru
qui a prévu 25 % de logements sociaux en
2025 dans toutes les communes sera
toujours applicable est ce que demain
les préfets auront toujours une
instruction pour appeler à l'ensemble
des maires qui doivent construire les
logements sociaux qu'ils ne peuvent pas
s'opposer au relogement des
bénéficiaires du droit au logement
opposable qui ne peuvent pas s'opposer à
la domiciliation des personnes sans
hébergement fixe qu'ils ne peuvent pas
enfin bloqué par des plans locaux
d'urbanisme la construction de logements
collectifs
voilà la bataille culturelle à mener
dans les mois qui viennent est ce qu'on
est pôle logement de l'ensemble des
français ou pour simplement une minorité
qui a les moyens
est-ce qu'on est pour l'égalité
territoriale ou pour simplement la
préservation de quelques intérêts
étaient eater territoriaux en tout cas
nous au gouvernement nous savons où est
notre camp